[Applause]
next i've got walter isaacson's going to
moderate a really great session on
innovation and education and certainly
walter doesn't need much introduction
either he's the chairman and
president and ceo of the aspen institute
he's been the ceo of cnn and the editor
of time magazine he's also a
best-selling
biographer so please help me welcome
walter
thank you thank you kevin
well our session right now is on
something that keeps coming up in our
conversation
which is education and how innovation
and technology are going to transform it
i think it's a useful topic
if ben franklin came back today and
walked into a classroom he'd say oh yeah
that's exactly how we did it that's
exactly what we made a teacher stands
there and gives a little lecture and 24
kids are sitting around it's a one major
sector of our lives that have not been
totally transformed by the digital
revolution and i think we're at an
inflection point it's about to happen
uh whether it's mit and harvard uh
joining up for edx the way stanford has
already been doing uh for higher
education or what's happening in the
k-12 classroom starting with you bill
you've um
written about four or five things are
going to be transformative but let me
start with the first one you talk about
which is reimagining textbooks how do
you think that's going to change and
make personalized education
well if you get pervasive digital
devices very cheap tablets and pervasive
internet connection then one can imagine
eliminating the paper-based textbook
and an interactive textbook is a very
different thing in fact the boundary
between quiz lecture textbook
is basically eviscerated you can track
the student
bring in a video ask them a few
questions to keep them engaged
and the invention of what that
multimedia educational thing
uh called the future textbook but it's
really all those things brought together
we're in the process of figuring out
what that is right now
and there's a lot of innovators
for-profit non-profit innovators who are
participating in that
i was at science math academy in our
hometown of new orleans where sal and i
come from uh run by some teacher america
corps members and there are no textbooks
they just have curriculum and the
teachers up there on the dashboard
saying oh these two students don't
understand that x and y are different
and these two
um how do you uh
do you think they'll be just a totally
disruptive transformation of how we do
curricula or do you think textbooks will
then just be put in digital form
well we want to be a little conservative
about this because
in a sense the
[Music]
every time something new comes along
they say education will change
um you know textbooks came along you
know anybody could read them we got tv
sets you know we got videotape
uh we got computer-aided instruction
and so far technology at least in the
classroom
has had absolutely no effect so the
issues of
motivation why should i learn this
am i the person who's good at this
there's so much complex human
uh motivation in the learning process
that to say that just to mechanize the
pieces like okay just click on the
lecture we don't need the lecture the
actual usage of things like mit open
courseware
is mind-blowing for one reason
basically nobody uses it i mean you know
take the very best walter lewin physics
course which is the third one up there
about 3 000 people have gone through the
thing and it's free it's fantastic i
love the guy
uh
but you know there's no market for for
people at home at night saying oh yeah
how do those wave equations work uh you
know without a job a degree
uh
so far this whole
you know hey it's online therefore it'll
be utterly different there's been as
many
failures as successes
now i think some of the stuff
that uh
saul and bro are involved in are going
to be amazingly successful so i do think
this time is is different so uh
everybody talks about flipping the
classroom
and you are the ones who've been
successful at that so far explain how
you think that's going to work
yeah you know when you go to this
reality and it's been happening already
i mean for us it's been kind of an
inadvertent adventure but you have this
reality where students are going to a
place and they're learning from videos
and exercises and getting feedback you
start to realize well okay well they can
all learn their own pace now and as soon
as you make that one assumption that
every student can learn at their own
pace master concepts and move on and
kind of build a scaffold it actually
allows you to rethink every aspect of
the education system you no longer have
to
group kids by age-based cohorts you
never you no longer have to have a
teacher in the front of the room giving
a lecture you no longer have to have to
have a all the all the all the desks
pointed in the same direction you no
longer have to have teachers separate
from each other you know i have 20
students you have 20 students and we
have no peer interaction and so what
we're seeing is and we're you know we
started off as kind of a virtual thing
for anybody out there who to learn
actually will you explain the story of
how you start oh yeah no i mean my heart
yeah new orleans connection you know i
right after i got married family from
new orleans was visiting me in boston
i'm now in northern california and uh 12
year old cousin nadia having trouble
with math and i offered to tutor her and
uh a little you know two years into it i
i
word got around to the family and i was
tutoring about 15 cousins and uh
and then i uh you know famously a friend
said well you know i was having trouble
scaling myself i had a day job and and
and he's
why you stick some lessons on youtube i
said no that that's that's for cats
playing piano not not real
math but then i gave it a shot and uh
you know famously my my cousins told me
they liked me better on youtube than in
person that's right and so i um
i kept going and and so yeah the youtube
videos you know there's there's there's
a ton of them now there's six million
kids using it every month now we're a
team of 30 people now um
but yeah so and we when we launched kind
of in a big way and we started building
our organization we assumed this is a
supplemental thing out for kids anywhere
to learn or adult learners too
but then some school districts said no
this is interesting to us this is kind
of different true differentiated
instruction this could be a game changer
and tell us what school districts have
adopted it and give me an example of how
that's worked yeah so uh the most
famously los altos in silicon valley
they're now district-wide but it's been
a a kip prep summit prep a couple of
other charter schools in oakland i think
the one that's actually pushed the
envelope the most is a marlborough
school in los angeles which is really an
elite girls school and what they did is
they said yeah no reason for we have to
do this prussian model where all
students learn at you know the same pace
and uh we're going to have a 7th to 12th
grade
girls all in the same classroom
all learning at their own pace and
there's if you visit one of these
classrooms there's a ton of peer-to-peer
interaction and what the teacher's doing
they're no longer the lecturer they're
they're doing one-on-one interactions
it's it's made the classroom a more of
an interactive or human experience broad
uh what have you learned about how
people learn and how does that get
applied and maybe even do it if you
would in an international context so
many people here from around the world
you know what have you learned from
around the world of how different people
learn things
and especially in your higher education
and career training
things at kaplan tell us how that works
what's great about working now at this
intersection between education
technology and actually learning science
is that all of these things are now
ready to go ready to get something
really done
and on the learning science side a lot
of the things that saul is describing uh
actually back up exactly what's being
found when you look experimentally at
how people actually learn and there's
been a lot of that work over the last 20
30 years
things like uh you know giving people
control over their pace
um and that turns out to help all
learners novices and expert learners um
things about using media together with a
voice over and that's exactly how saul
khan's videos work he doesn't show his
face he's actually showing a key you
know write-up as he's doing it so your
eye is tracking what he's actually
talking about that turns out to line up
with a bunch of the research about how
you should use media things about using
simple informal language
things about technology then allow you
to take a really good learning solution
because the best tutors do these kinds
of things too
what technology lets you do is take a
good solution
or actually a bad solution
and make it affordable reliable
available and data rich
so all of those things now become
possible for us to do and it's possible
for us to do around the globe you know
the the materials that you create that
are introductory materials and
demonstration materials can suddenly
become available to everyone around the
globe
and then you have local folks who get
together to provide that next stage of
feedback and counseling and answering
questions that the online materials
don't actually describe and that local
work can also then become you know
culturally more connected to where you
are and give examples from where that is
happening as well it gives a terrific
opportunity to make the whole process
much more efficient around time and
effort and what it actually does and
this is a little bit odd but it it
begins to drag education into the modern
economy where to do all this you
actually have to spend a lot more effort
up front this is not typically somebody
sitting down the night before and doing
a whole course it becomes well let's
look at the learning science let's think
about our objectives let's structure
this thing let's figure out where do the
interactives go when do we need a person
to engage when we can use the automated
systems that can be a lot you build all
that
but now your variable costs come down
potentially because you're using
teachers well-trained human beings in a
system for what they're really good at
and allow the machines and the tools and
the media to be designed to do the rest
really well too so at kaplan you know as
a business doing this kind of work we're
trying very hard now to actually use
large scale we have more than a million
learners to begin to generate data to do
experiments along these lines just as
saul is doing to see if we apply this
learning science now at scale as a
learning engineering exercise can we get
those benefits and then can we keep
going and scale and transform how we do
all our education this is a very
exciting time so what broad just
described is really how our for-profit
model can work well because you can do
the upfront cost do it to scale yours is
a non-profit model then we have the
model sort of the harvard mit doing edx
and stanford doing it two different
things whatever it may be how do you see
the mix of profits non-profits and
what's the advantages of each and this
yeah i think it's all great i think we
really are in kind of a renaissance and
i mean every week we're hearing a new i
mean you know harvard and mit these are
not small institutions this was i think
it was the biggest that i have four
degrees from amongst them right yeah so
i'm making sure that they'll never got
one as far as i can remember right yeah
he's getting a higher return on his but
um
the the um
the the uh
you know you know i think it's all great
it's all innovation i think everyone's
seeing what works in certain contexts
and saying hey we should do that too we
should do that you know our thought or
my thought process process and it was
really kind of delusional when i
literally was operating out of a closet
and for for several years um it was that
you know we are at kind of this
inflection point in history uh we've
been talking about it this this whole
session and and um
i felt that any inflection point in in
history needs new institutions
and uh
it wasn't obvious that new institutions
at at to this point had actually
percolated up new companies have been
not new institutions and so in my
delusional i read a lot of science
fiction books i was like
maybe i could be like harry selden in
the foundation you know that this could
this could this could uh
we could read the same books obviously
but but the but there are people who
read the foundation yeah yes yeah isaac
asked vanguard yeah but but there is i
mean it it was crazy and kind of uh
idealistic on one aspect but on another
aspect it's completely practical now
maybe we could do civilization scale
education we can make it free we can
make it an institution i mean this
content i talked about you know if
newton had made videos on calculus i
wouldn't have to
this stuff is evergreen it's not
changing well his notation was a little
yeah he was a little extensive
that might have been yeah for him
but but so this stuff is evergreen this
stuff is gonna you know these videos
could be teaching not just videos
interactions questions simulations they
could teach kids 500 years from now and
so it just seemed like too
crazy of an opportunity to try to i mean
there's nothing wrong with it as a
business but
maybe it can be an institution and that
was that was the thinking for us bill
how does that
change the role of the teachers and help
you scale good teachers
well what we'd really like to know is
why is it so hard to get kids motivated
around these things i mean after all
it's really in the kids interest to get
a high school degree and get a college
degree it's not just you make more money
you meet more interesting people
everything is better about
that path in life and so our failure
to
convince them to help themselves in that
way it's very disappointing and the us
statistics are horrific
we doubled what we put into education
over the last 20 years
and our
output did not improve at all and other
countries on the other hand
have done very very well
so
as for younger students
there's going to be a structured
environment
where teachers is there supervising them
quite a bit
uh one of the most interesting things a
conference hall and i went to we heard
about a thing called the lion school
which is a charter school in california
which in the us is where most the good
experimentation takes place they have a
class of 48
but when they ask the kids what they
liked about the class they said oh it's
it's so small and personal well it's
because they have 16 with the teacher
16 doing peer education and peer
education where you have kids
to help other kids that is a coming
thing and figuring out how to
technologically
uh
help those kids group together make that
work it's that is super powerful it's
also very cheap uh and then they have a
final group of 16 where they're just
looking at uh khan academy type content
playing some of the math game things and
so you do math in the by rotating
through the three different experiences
and their results are way better
than a class of 25 done the the normal
way
you just said that most of the
experimentation innovation being done
from some of the innovative charter
schools in the country uh in new orleans
now almost every kid goes to a charter
school and the parents have choice it's
almost a voucher system where the money
follows the student so you have
competition where a kip and a yes and a
whatever do it why
shouldn't that be the model as it is
with higher education where there's
competition people have choice why
shouldn't that be the model to drive
innovation in k-12
well it's not like higher ed is
fantastic
the dropout rates in university u.s
universities are
higher than any other country their
costs have also gone up
actually more than a factor of two in
the last 20 years and the output has not
improved all that much so there's
pathologies there as well
the
uniform approach sort of monolithic
state-by-state approach that we have yes
that probably holds things back
but politically
to get that to change is very hard i
mean charter schools
california shorts their charter schools
in a way that most of them are
are financially unstable right now
and
you know the union uh
often argues for the status quo whether
it's against charters or against
personnel systems uh so it's very very
tough because everybody wants a minimum
standard and using a market-based
approach you worry that you you won't
hit that minimum and so you get this
kind of rigid
uh approach is the the acceptable is
that good or bad
well
i don't know how to
it's it's very hard to change
um there are countries that do this
better than we do and you'd hope that we
could learn from them so you have can we
learn how to do personal systems and
then can you bring technology in those
are the two things that should make you
optimistic
about
education that uh
people like kaplan
are
on a for-profit basis and things like
khan academy really are going to catch
on
um but the institutions will be slow to
recognize these things thank goodness
for charters and some young teachers who
are willing to
essentially break the rules
uh broad
why do you think the profit model will
succeed in a world where so many people
are now doing this for free
it's a great question but part of it is
because as we just talked about
technology is not the only answer it
doesn't actually solve all of the human
training needs the human mind is is
built to take a lot of feedback a lot of
customized feedback and to use that very
well there are some things that you can
automate and over time there will be
more and more things but at the end of
the day if you're trying to write a
persuasive essay
you need somebody to give you feedback
on why it's not persuasive and how to do
it again and then to look and see did
you get it right this time or not
another aspect of this why i think you
know there's real value that that people
will pay for is connecting the outcomes
of education itself to the outcomes that
are needed let's say in the workplace so
a lot of our work is in the higher
education space so folks go from us to
the workplace to many of your businesses
perhaps
and one of the missing things in higher
education is a very clear link between
how are people doing in their first six
months of work and how should that
shouldn't that be a feedback loop that
comes back to the training environments
or the learning environments to modify
those and from dr kahneman's work last
night discussion last night one of the
fundamental barriers is the system one
system two problem which is
that experts more than half of what is
human expertise in an expert's mind is
subconscious that is
when they teach a novice as you do you
stick an expert up in front and have
them teach they will tell a novice less
than
30 percent of what the novice needs to
know to execute it's why your first year
in any job is in agony it's because all
the experts before you ended up not
telling you more than 30 of what you
needed to know the first day on your job
there are techniques and we're
experimenting with those at kaplan that
come out of cognitive science and i've
talked with some of you about those
things
called cognitive task analysis where you
identify with objective measures out of
a thousand people in your workforce who
are the three that you want to clone who
are the three who are making decisions
that are amazing for your business in
their role
and then you can do an interview process
to get more like 70 percent of that
and then create training materials and
methods and practice that targets
those skills put those in place and
begin the feedback loop on a with an
objective reason you can make it clear
transparent what you're trying to do and
why and that allows you to change it
over time too as the job role changes
you keep interviewing new experts and
you make adjustments well now that takes
real work i mean and repeated work it's
also enormously valuable for both you as
employers and for the employees to now
sign on and know that the training track
is leading to high quality expertise
that's been validated in the workplace
so what to me what's happening now and
it's terrific is
the free solutions are providing an
increasing baseline of learning
materials right you know you can't get
away with you know poorly designed
lectures and then ignore the students
right it's just no that's not going to
work anymore there's all this great free
materials to provide a baseline
and then above that that's where it gets
exciting what comes after that what
feedback do you do how do you design
outcomes to improve on what's available
that's free and i think it'll be just
like always in technology and ever
increasing
in a sense race that way and so i think
that's part of what's exciting about it
so you can remember your days at mit and
at harvard uh khan academy has no such
campuses kaplan has places where people
go but they aren't quite campuses like
that what is the role if any that actual
physical campuses with human interaction
should and will play i i think it's a
huge role and i think the the important
part is what you just said the human
interaction and and the problem is if
you go to most campuses right now yeah
we're all in the same room but there's
actually very little human interaction i
mean i used to sit in 300 person lecture
halls
whole semester i didn't know the
professor i didn't know i might have
known two people in the classroom by the
way every professor who taught you
claims yeah they they saw potential back
then yeah i don't know
they um more people build computer
science and harvard than they were never
taught there yeah yeah
but but uh so so what what i said you
know when i imagine school for my own
children i i imagine a highly
interactive environment and so what we
think is that you know education is the
spectrum at this end is your you know
multiplication facts and vocabulary and
then out here is building a robot
starting a business painting a picture i
mean really open-ended creative things
and what we see the role of technology
is okay we're already doing this part
and we're going to keep pushing the
envelope we'll use data we'll make it
better and better and better and we'll
iterate on it and we'll connect it to uh
real economic valuable things and then
as we do this there's kind of some fear
that i that you know oh well is this
going to because right now this is where
school is focused is this going to
replace the teachers there it's going to
turn them into you know monitors of some
kind no no this is an opportunity to
move the humans over here where the
humans are good
bill what do you think the role of
things like social networks and gaming
are in transforming education
well it's fascinating that um one of the
educational startups this one grockett
has the ability to do
sat testing all these things and you can
just do the quizzes on your own
or you can do them with a group of
people
and
overwhelmingly over 90 percent people
choose to do it almost as a contest
where if somebody is slow then you can
say wow you you know you go on a social
network you mean well it's online
multiple people interacting the word
social network but it's not place based
it's no it's online exactly uh
no it's a ten dollars a month thing
where you sign up and you have access
and you can do solo
uh tests or you can go into this sort of
gaming like thing now the gaming thing
some people really take it where they
design a very rich interactive game
uh manga high's a
for-profit that's done a pretty strong
set of games for math
uh our foundation is funding a lot of
people like zoran popovic over uw and
others to do some rich games that have a
uh
a way of engaging you in some
mathematical things that you may not
even realize that you're you're learning
so there's a lot of promise there
you know gaming and simulation hopefully
can make the subject more approachable
more interesting more hands-on
kia henderson was walking the hall of
chancellor of the washington dc schools
and was explaining that with gaming
there's something odd which is that the
boys take to it because it's a real
competition and they will stay up all
night to beat their friends and get more
points and suddenly be 50 percent ahead
but and i don't want to just make it a
gender-based thing but different people
learn differently and that gaming uh in
some ways turn some other people off do
you see that
we do see that actually i mean the the
first complaint when the los altos pilot
started was there was a subset of boys
who got addicted to it literally like
they could i mean it was a good
addiction i guess but yeah
they were learning math but they were
just couldn't get them their parents
couldn't get them to focus on anything
else
what a problem yeah yeah no there are
worse things
the the but but what we did see is there
there are also ways to motivate girls
with game mechanics and it's not obvious
it's a distribution and and we have seen
that girls are
more focused on achievement more focused
on what they've done more focused on
their portfolio of of actions while uh
boys are more focused on on points and
and maybe we don't outgrow it for some
of us
i think if people haven't outgrown it
let me open it up for questions uh
please uh if we can turn up the lights
and raise some hands and uh get started
one thing i might say about the gaming
side which is it is actually very
interesting because the risk is some of
the gaming elements can wind up being
more distracting and helpful but once
you kind of get an initial mastery then
the gaming elements provide that
encouragement for repeated practice
which is what's needed to build a lot of
fluency and familiarity so that the
skills begin to be embedded so there's
this careful trade-off between when
you're initially instructing and trying
to get ideas across the very first
examples you show and then practice
environments are exciting and engaging
and as you've written about that
mastering that comes from is something
we sometimes miss yes exactly the
traditional education structure we
lecture then we test but we don't give
that and games can do that yourself yes
games can do that but so can uh simple
things like worked examples where you go
from showing talking about what you need
to do then you give a demonstration it
turns out demonstrations are enormously
important show somebody doing what you
said and then you do what's called the
worked example where you give people
partially filled out work and so there
you do a piece they do a piece you do
piece they do a piece it's exactly what
the best tutors actually do
but the technology now allows you to
take what is a very effective and
expensive learning technique and turn it
into something that can be distributed
on us and that gives you then that
experience and and builds the mastery
and confidence and it turns out it
shrinks learning time and increases the
amount of mastery
you should read his blog by the way
number one